okay like if this is my podcast no no
please we love we love this can i ask
you how your feelings on people care
okay none i want it gone you want none
of that exactly
yeah i i personally don't mind a pube
i don't want a piece of a single hair
no if she misses one pup i don't mind if
it's two
yeah don't let her have two people i
don't want a pube i don't mind a full
bush
i think because the reason why is i
think the the first
porn that i started to watch like that
the point that was taped around uh that
was passed around because you know you
should be vhs
yeah um the women had full bushes porn
yeah so i just and i enjoyed it you know
yeah it was um
it was full bush porn and uh
so i don't mind it to be honest with you
though i
can't tell you the last time i've been
with a woman who's had pubes i mean i
don't think people don't do it anymore i
don't know i've been toying with growing
mind back lately
well i i you wouldn't it wouldn't deter
me i mean styles are cyclical i love it
i love a bush i love a bush
it's not i don't i have zero like i'm
not out here
getting bikini waxes for any man or
anything just for comfortability like it
just gets itchy down there it's just
annoying
right and a bikini season comes it's a
mess yeah so it's really just
like yeah for me when i was with my
kid's mom i wasn't allowed to shave my
pubes because then she would think like
if i shaved my pubes
i was going to have sex with somebody so
so now that you know i've been single i
just i have
the i have the biggest push i mean i
have full bush that's the blocker
that's i bet you that's one of those
ears one of those hairs got my ear what
do you guys like
do you like bush i just i just want you
to maintain what you have going on i
just went on what
i've never had a situation i don't know
tell me if you have i've never had a
situation where i've gone down there and
been like
holy [ __ ] something's wrong you know
i've just never been with a guy that
didn't like manscape
i one guy i remember like running my
fingers through it and then
to cross you out a little bit it was too
much like when you like why this guy two
shirt trent
two shirts right so to kind of tell the
story
yeah please his friends called him
t-shirt trent and they were like he only
has two shirts actually and i'm like
that's gotta be an exaggeration oh i
thought it was because he wore two
shirts at a time at all times like the
two pockets like dollars
and he only owned two and i was like
that's ridiculous
and then one day i slept over this place
finger comb the pubes the night before
he went to work and he was like
stay here let yourself out we actually
lived in the same apartment complex he
was like stay here let yourself out
whenever
and i was like okay and i was like i'm
gonna open that closet
one shirt on a hanger so one shirt on
him
one shirt on a hanger and i called my
friend i was like get over here
he really owns two shirts no
and then for my birthday he really liked
me and he bought himself a third shirt
went to the ball
got a [ __ ] bird that was a big day for
him right there and he had a full bush
this kid
i was like yes but i was like i feel
like i don't like him at all i'm like i
need to break
up with him and my friend karen was like
ashley he was friends with her boyfriend
she was like chad told me karen and chad
there this she was like chad told me
that he trains at the mall
getting a shirt for your birthday and i
was like i can't bring up with this guy
like
you got a stir shirt yeah that would be
rough
he was like i got i got a shirt for i
got the only other shirt that i
owned for this boy did you dump him
though anyway yeah we like i usually
what i used to do when i still
and she waited till i paid off the
credit card bill that month let's watch
the market
i usually just get really wasted and
like burn it to the ground yeah yeah
smart
you just do something so crazy i would
expect the kid who wants cubes
yeah he only owned two shirt i would
expect that kid to not manscape
if he took care of everything else in
the rest of his life but he only had two
shirts that would right weird i would
like to know what guys are really doing
down there like is it a like a a
like an electric shaver i use a mach 3
in the shower yeah
and then i wash after that and then i
just rub like a whole bunch of lotion on
it or something like i just don't know
what push
if i shave no if i'm going full bush
then i just wash my bush like my hair
just changes
you you what do you say i shaved my butt
i shave it in the shower
i shave my i don't put shaving cream on
my dick and balls i just while the
shower is running i'll just shave
okay are you a hairy guy not too hairy
but um i shaved my balls yeah with a
with a razor oh so you got you're you're
big
you're i just fit your balls i don't
like going out in the world without
shave balls
really yeah my mood's on top isn't it
not it's not itchy not itchy at all he
also
our fans real quick our fans have said
uh put the witch hazel in the
refrigerator
they said cold witch hazel works better
okay how do you how do you get it in
your choices
yeah and she's been showering it's clean
yeah
yeah i think you got a witch hazel your
[ __ ] so you put it up your [ __ ]
or does your wife do it um not yet
she hasn't yet but when we get more
comfortable yeah now that we're married
she has no rights anymore you guys are
married
exactly that was in the valley i traded
i traded three goats for her
now she has to wish hazel your butthole
with a q-tip
you actually penetrate your bottle or
you just do the rim i just take toilet
paper i pour some witch holes
on it and it's one when i want a 100
clean ass uh-huh
because usually i think you're either 90
92 97 percent
shower's not gonna get you 100 cleaners
okay not not an american
american showerhead so you can get that
that's a problem in america you know
they you can't bring the party to the
church you do it in my
in my kitchen though i have a removable
hose you can have it you have a clean
ass i could yeah and you're short you
can climb up there and [ __ ] oh
squadron
no doubt i can fit in the sink yeah i i
use a little fence
but people said in our podcast that
luffas are filled with bacteria and
they're disgusting
probably oh yeah can i do it like i'll
do it on like my fingertip and just kind
of go around my [ __ ] you can
[Music]
you can you can get creative at whole
foods develop your whole stuff it's your
own style you could amazon it
they also have wipes it'll be the final
frontier of friendship a witch hazel
you're asking so do you guys know how
you bleach an [ __ ]
no no so at my old bikini waxing place
used in atlanta
she started doing [ __ ] bleachings and
i was like how do you do it and she was
like you literally just have to
rim around and with your finger until
it's bleached with
actual okay i have a crazy question what
do they
massage the bleach into your what's the
action of it yeah
so some girls have like some girls have
like a brown [ __ ]
that's not it's not it's not [ __ ]
residue it's just they're i don't know
what it is
my butt is like the same color through
and through i'm just i'm pink all over
your [ __ ] i have explored every
crevice of my body it's all the same
color people have some brown down there
but what would be the what would be the
okay so like
i don't know it's just like a skin i
mean your skin is different colors
yeah but no but i mean like skin okay if
i had if i had something on my skin that
i
but like i mean who's seeing the inside
of your [ __ ] i understand people say
it's not the inside it's around the rim
it's a different color so in other words
like in a bikini you'd be able to see a
brown ass
oh no only if you okay so if i bent over
and i like spread my cheeks out
what if you're staring into my star the
color of the star would be like a
different color a girl would be getting
her [ __ ] bleach if she thinks she's
going to be having
sex from the bed like yeah like butt sex
a lot earlier never had butt sex ever in
my life
not once okay we should yeah we should
date that sounds great oh yeah i've
never done it
i've never done i've tried i've tried to
finagle it in a girl's butt it just
doesn't work and i'd rather like [ __ ]
you in your ear than your ass
you don't like that lubricated no i
don't like it it's it's not now it's dry
yeah i don't i'm not a big fan i've
never eaten an ass either yeah i've
never done anything with a butt
i've got horned up and licked a few
hands do you guys like it yes
i had one girl against my will stick her
finger in my ass
um and was blowing me and stuck her
finger my ass and it was against my will
initially but it did feel really good so
that's why you don't like it at first
because like you you have to be warned
when it's gonna happen
warm it up i was like whoa whoa whoa and
she's like just relax babe
but you know what people say you know
what my theory on that is people
say like oh you like a finger it's like
yeah i i like a finger on my ass when
i'm getting my dick sucked
okay so i think the dick sucked is the
big part of that yeah like you could
shoot me in the head while you're
sucking my dick i'll be like i like
getting shot in the head with my kids
oh you know what i mean no i don't blow
jobs though no i disagree
men have uh you have nerve endings in
your prostate so you have like a [ __ ] in
your butt
you have um like a whole spot in your
butt you have to call it a
tourist a chautaurus that's hilarious
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.com where things get
really wild